check this out
so what you're seeing here is
neurocellular automata
that are learned to communicate with
each other
what digit they compose so every pixel
you see
is like a little cell and it
communicates with its
neighbors and only its immediate
neighbors um
about kind of its surroundings and
by doing that all these cells that are
connected components have to agree
as to what digits they compose and here
you can see the seven
uh symbolized by gray and the three
symbolized by green
uh reach an agreement there are some
interesting
properties about these cellular automata
namely here you can see
that half of this thinks it's a two and
the address things it's a
zero however let's see when i complete
this now it's too
it's too smart for this
well look at that now it thinks a bit
it's an eight so
you can clearly see there's like some
message passing some evolution
going on across the states right here
it doesn't work perfectly i found it
thinks a lot of times that it is
in fact a zero um
as you can see right here but so the
goal is
that this this direction of research
isn't about state-of-the-art in digit
classification
as you might be able to uh determine
right here
it's about neural cellular automata and
i highly recommend if you don't know yet
go watch my video or read the previous
article in this distil
pub journal about growing neurocellular
automata
this paper here is a follow-up it's
called self-classifying mnist digits
and it's by ettore randazzo alexander
mortwinsef
edwin nicholson and sorry ivan nicholson
michael levin and sam gradiness
so this paper is an evolution of the
previous paper
and i'm going to switch back and forth
here between the website
and the thing where i can scribble on so
bear
with me for that they're saying that
growing neural cellular automata
demonstrated how
simple cellular automata can learn to
self-organize into complex shapes while
being resistant to perturbation so that
was the last paper
such a computational model approximates
a solution to an open question biology
namely how do cells cooperate to create
a complex
multicellular anatomy and work to
regenerate it upon damage
also from the last paper the model
parameterizing the cell's rule is
parameter efficient and when
differentiable and illustrates a new
approach to modeling the regulation of
anatomical homeostasis homeostasis
okay in this work we use a version of
this model to show how cellular automata
can be applied to common tasking machine
learning classification
we pose the question can cellular
automata use
local message passing to achieve global
agreement on what digit they compose
so that's the question right here now
again i've done a video on cellular
automata but
really really briefly um what you saw
above
is that there's an image and it's
rasteride of course
rasterized in two pixels and each pixel
represents one cell so you can think of
this
as basically nodes in a graph
and each cell is connected to its
immediate
neighbors so each cell let's take this
one is connected to
all its immediate neighbors like so
and of course each cell each other cell
again is connected to
its immediate neighbors now all
they know is basically
the so if i draw something on this
canvas
let's say i draw let's take this i draw
a two
okay then you look at this cell right
here
and of course the cell this is going to
be
it's the line would be thicker so it's
either going to be
on or off it's either going to be i
painted on it or i didn't paint on it
and it can be in different
variations like there is an alpha level
but ultimately
the each cell can only register whatever
was said painted on it okay
so each cell can be dead or alive
and dead cells they will not send around
any messages and dead cells is
everywhere where there is no color at
all
so this would be a dead cell this would
be a dead cell
this one wouldn't be a dead cell because
there is a little bit of color
um this would be a dead cell right here
so with this so you can see that most
cells here are actually
dead now the cells that aren't that they
register whatever is painted on them
like this cell or this cell or this cell
and then
they need to communicate that to each
other and the goal is that all these
cells that are alive
like these cells right here all the
they pass messages to each other
such that they all come to an agreement
what digit they compose
right if you imagine you're this cell
right here
all you see is that there is a bit of
purple on you
right uh there is a bit of purple
and it could be alpha level 200 out of
and only by registering this and
communicating this
to your neighbors and receiving messages
and then passing on those messages to
other neighbors
all of these cells need to come to an
agreement so how
do these cells agree each cell in fact
has a
cell state so each of these cells has a
cell state
and that cell state first and foremost
composes is composed of
10 different slots one for each class
so what does it mean to agree on
something
at the end of this procedure or over
time
each cell in each round of communication
can update its own
cell state and whatever number
is highest right here so this could be a
high number this could be a low number
i'm drawing like sideway histograms
whatever one
is the highest right here that's what
the cell believes
the class is so you immediately see
a bit how this is going to be trained so
this is going to be trained by these
authors taking an mnist digit
placing that on the cells letting this
whatever procedure run
if the procedure is differentiable right
you let it run for a number of time
steps
and in each time step you basically
impose a cross
entropy classification loss on these 10
entries in the cell state
that way you train the cells to
output the correct digit now each cell
has to do that by itself so the goal is
to devise
a communication algorithm such that each
cell communicates with each other
cell such that at the end all the cells
will
um will be updated as to what the
global state is as is what the digit
comprises
okay so what is this message
passing right here and for that i think
we need to first of all
imagine what is actually passed around
here so if you
see this sample above right here and you
imagine
let's say we are actually in this
configuration on the left and there is a
slight
bend let's say here we're in this part
of the number two
there's a slight bend right here so what
you can see
maybe um let me draw this a bit more
clear
is that for example this
the blue cell will register
will by message passing it can it can
register that there is an alive cell
right here
but this alive cell will also register
that there is no
there is a dead cell next to it right so
it can pass on that message to the blue
cell and the blue cell will sort of know
that ah there is kind of a border
um over there then also diagonally to
the blue cell it will register itself
wow there is a dead cell right here
and that's right below this alive cell
above so there must be some kind of a
bend
right here you can already see how
through this sort of message passing and
this cell right here of course will its
neighbor
is also dead through this message
passing these cells can kind of figure
out together
the kind of more global shapes and they
will recognize ah there is a bend
it's it's something like this right and
then other cells
maybe down here will figure out well
there is a actually a corner
right here okay and then other cells on
top here they will figure out well there
is actually a
bend like this and then they can
communicate this to each other
so these cells right here that have the
corner
they will at some point receive this
integrated message that there is a bend
on top and then they can make sense of
that right and say well we are a corner
and there is a bend on top and there is
so there must be a digit that's
something like
this right and you can already see that
at that point they can be fairly sure
that this is a two
um so you can see that the combination
of message passing
and kind of uh think
each cell thinking by itself can give
rise to this kind of
each cell coming into global agreement
not only agreement but correct agreement
right so the message passing itself
again described in the last paper but
really briefly there is these 10 entries
right
here that decide on what the cell
believes the state is and then you can
have extra entries that are just kind of
latent state there is no loss imposed on
these latent
variables but ultimately the cell state
consists of this
long vector and then this vector is
passed on to
all the neighbors okay this vector is
passed to all the neighbors
and all the neighbors send their own
state vector to this cell now
the state vectors of all the neighbor
cells are then integrated so each one
has this vector
vector vector vector vector these are
all integrated together with the
own state of the um
of the cell in a linear fashion so
there's like a small
neural network in between and that will
update
the cell state in fact i think they
calculate a diff
to the cell state they don't calculate
the new cell state by definition it they
actually calculate a
diff and this should remind you
of so if you if we just look at this one
dimensionally
right so here's the cell and there is
its neighbor
its neighbor its neighbor neighbor and
then the diagonal neighbors
and we want to update this cell
right here as a linear combination
of all the cells surrounding it
and itself and we want to do that
for each so each cell has the same
update rule right so it doesn't matter
where the cell is you're trying to come
up with one rule
how to integrate the surrounding states
into
cell itself and this is so the
biological
kind of reasoning behind it is that all
the cells follow the same rules but by
virtue of where they are
and how they communicate uh these global
patterns can arise
and you know this this cell will update
and then if we consider the next cell
next to it
it has its neighbors it will update
according to its neighbors
this should remind you of a convolution
right because this is exactly
the convolution so there will be a
convolutional operator a three by three
convolutional operator
right here this can be multi-channel of
course because we have
multiple channels right here in the cell
state
so the convolution will be learned
once globally which is exactly what a
convolutional operator is a
convolutional kernel
it will be learned to update these cell
states in fact it's a it's a residual
convolutional connection right this
goes through the convolutional kernel
and is then added together
with the signal itself to give rise to
the new cell
states so one convolution across the
entire image
will take care of updating all the cells
is one round of message passing
and then now contrary to a convolutional
neural network where then the signal
would go into the next layer into the
next convolutional kernel
um sorry
this is then repeated with the same
convolutional kernel right the message
passing algorithm is the same
in each round so this is a recurrent
neural network
with a residual convolution as an
operator
that is the model for kind of the
biological
cell communication algorithm
so these are these neural cellular
automata the difference to the last
paper is
twofold first of all in the last paper
we had rgb values up here
now it's the class labels so these are
also passed around so that the cell
passes to its neighbors what it believes
the current
labels are but also these hidden
features right here and we'll come to
this
in a second and this the second
difference
is that um the dead and the live cells
are static
so where these dead cells where the dead
cells and where the alive cells are that
never changes
that used to change in the last paper
here it never changes it's only about
passing the
messages around between the cells
all right so the
um this is this is basically it so this
is a model
for agreement between cells i think it's
it's pretty cool
um i would still like to
go more into what kind of what exactly
happens what kind of messages are passed
around
but they they do this a little bit
so they have a bunch of experiments how
do they train this stuff basically how
do they train this stuff
that i can you know i can change it in
between and it will actually
it will update it uh live so the cells
you can't only do this once the cells
must have a notion of continuously
being alive continuously updating
themselves continuously being prepared
that there is
some sort of a modification to the cell
and that's they do this by
so here you can see can i zoom
well i can't
now i can here you can see um that
this is how they train it so they just
initialize the cell states randomly
that's why you see there are just random
colors
right here these are amnesty and then
they train these cells
all of them to predict the label of the
mnist digits which they have in the
training set and then so you can see
once you've trained it that happens
fairly fairly quickly
and then after 200 steps they simply
switch out the digit
okay they leave all the cells as they
are of course some cells will be dead
now and some cells will be alive the
ones that come alive will just be
initialized randomly
but there are always going to be cells
that are going to be present in both
digits and those
will just keep the label but you know
usually the
the digit here changes with a 90
probability
and since this is one long run of a
recurrent network
the network sort of has to always
be prepared for a change because it's
trained
with this mutation so it's trained for
200 steps in the first digit and then
it's switched and trained for 200 steps
with the second label that causes these
cells to kind of always be ready for
change
and that's yeah so you can see there are
still some artifacts where the cells
that they're not quite sure
and so on and in fact they get worse
over time if you pay real
close attention towards the end of these
cycles
it actually gets worse so after a while
some of them will start flickering up
again
and that's a problem they've observed
and they go into this
right here so they have these graphs of
accuracy
over time so accuracy
means average cell accuracy so they just
take all the cells and they see how many
of them are correct and you can see
at the beginning of training pretty
quickly sorry at the beginning
this is inference so inference of course
you also do
over time right so this is in inference
you provide
a digit you initialize randomly and then
you let these cells communicate so you
run the recurrent convolutional
algorithm
and you count how many cells output the
correct label at each step
and pretty quickly reaches high up and
then you can see at the mutation it
drops down to random again but
also pretty quickly recovers so it
sounds pretty good but you can see a
teeny tiny
bit right here it's kind of going down
after
you know over time and
so they determine um they need to do
something about this
in fact they first of all they want to
make a point
that you have to figure out what exactly
is happening so here they have average
cell
accuracy but what they also decide to
measure is average
total agreement across the batch
so average total agreement basically
means how many of the cells within
a digit agree with each other
uh on the on the label which is sort of
a measure if this is really an
mnist digit you know it should be
perfectly in one
class and not the other i know there's
some ambiguity
but so what you should have at least
even if the cells are wrong you should
have a total agreement
on in the cells if this is in fact a
digit
the cells should somehow agree with each
other because that's what you train them
to you train them to agree with each
other and you can see
again here as well pretty quickly you
have an agreement
after a number of steps and then that
agreement drops again
strangely right because they've already
reached an agreement
you might think this will sort of maybe
it will
hamper down but it might slightly go up
but no it actually slightly goes down
over time so why is that
they also analyzed this here and i'm
sorry about this uh chopped up
graph but you can see that
the here are the state values here are
the sizes
the real numerical sizes of these
entries in the states
and you can see that they grow over time
so not only do they grow
until the agreement is reached but also
they keep growing after that and
here are the diffs from state to state
and you can also see that
these never go to zero so why is that
and they have a hypothesis right here
in fact they have the hypothesis this is
due to the cross
entropy loss now in the cross entropy
loss is
kind of the most famous loss for
classification so usually what you'll
have is your
neural network will output some
distribution like this
let's say it's three classes so it
believes that class number two here is
the
correct class and then you have a
label which you transform into a one hot
distribution
where this is one these are zero and
then you
you perform this cross entropy loss
between the two
saying that the left thing should be
more equal to
the right thing and you do that in the
sense of
so
this this is the kind of the entropy um
formulation but what you actually do is
this y
log p so p here is going to be
the distribution that you output and y
is going to be the distribution that the
network outputs you can pretty clearly
see
y is going to be zero for all the
classes that are wrong
wise so the entire loss reduces to
simply
the probability here
of the sorry that there is a negative uh
the probability
of the class that is correct so what you
want to do is you want to push
that up now of course so in just
just looking at the loss only the
correct class is pushed up
nothing else is done now
you also know that most of the time we
combine this with a so-called softmax
operator so what our network outputs
isn't actually a distribution it's what
we call
log it so an unnormalized distribution
so
what it actually outputs could be
something like this a high number a
negative number and a negative number
and only by matter of normalization
we reach this distribution right so the
softmax
operator will take care of normalizing
and also the softmax operator because of
the normalization when we backpropagate
this loss
it causes this logit here to rise and it
causes
these ones to lower because
of this normalization step not actually
because of the loss
so i think they so they correctly say
here is the cross entropy loss but it is
the cross
entropy loss combined with the softmax
operator
that we usually use in neural networks
that makes this phenomenon happen so
what is actually happening here
if you look at the softmax operator what
it does is it's like e to the
x divided by the sum of e to the
x prime over all over all other classes
so you can
fairly easily see that this exponential
function here
is never ever ever going to be zero
so you can never have a zero entry
right here so the loss
forces you to push this thing up but
because you can never have zero entries
there of course this can never be one
so you can never actually reach perfect
loss and
what does it do to the logits you cannot
reach perfect loss but the gradient will
always
push you into the direction of upping
this logit
and downing these so raising the one
that is correct
and lowering actually into the negative
direction
the ones that aren't correct so you can
see that if we do this once no problem
if we do this in
a single neural network forward
propagate we calculate loss
not a problem but if we do this over and
over and over and over again
in a convolutional neural network and we
let it run for infinite time
of course what is going to happen is
that these things are going to
explode more and more and more so these
losses are going to get bigger and
bigger which makes the entire rest of
the network behave in a bigger and
bigger fashion that's exactly
what you see here because these
simply the numerical values in the
states they will be bigger and bigger
and bigger
because they push the network into the
direction of
more and more and more reducing the loss
thereby
raising the logget so there's it's very
disproportionate
at the end you have to raise the logits
by a lot to
reduce the loss a little bit but the
network doesn't care because that's what
it was trained to do
so they hypothesize if we use an l2 loss
this shouldn't happen now in an l2 loss
you do not compare
you don't output lockets you output
actual
probabilities and you simply compare the
l2 distance
to them so if you compare the l2
distance right here
yes you will push this one up but if you
push it too high
then it's too high and then it will be
pushed down again until it is exactly
the same level as the other one now the
disadvantages here is that of course
this
isn't actually forced to be a valid
probability distribution
you can normalize it yes but you can go
too high
so you can output probabilities higher
than one and
so on so there's a whole slew of
problems that come with this
but you can counter this
so beside using an l2 loss they also
have a another
on top idea in that they always add
noise to these
residual updates that they do after the
convolution just kind of to keep the
network
on its toes uh saying that everything
can always change
with noise so in each step it basically
has to do some of some correction
with respect to that noise and here you
can see the clear
difference especially in the lower plot
where the total agreement before
this blue line was when it went down
over time and now with the l2 loss
and even a little bit more with this
residual noise it manages to keep the
total agreement
up and solve that problem
and you can also see that the average
magnitude of the updates no longer is
rising over time but actually it keeps
it's keeping the same for the cell
states and the updates converge towards
zero of course not as much with the
noise because the noise makes them
the noise will make them non-zero the
updates
but still they are at the same magnitude
so they manage to correct that noise and
not
incorporate more and more and more
likely cross-entropy
loss so this
i don't want to go into the last few
bits except this one
these cells have some interesting
properties notably they're also
resistant to
kind of out of distribution errors
and we can see that in this video
where uh you can see it's classifying it
fairly solidly as
once but as soon as you and he's this
is supposed to be a seven but as soon as
you draw a shape that is not
kind of in the training or set or
in the classes of the training set the
cells
they keep disagreeing with each other
and so this you can see as sort of kind
of a
robustness to out of distribution
samples
and it's also pretty interesting to see
that the messages here
where they go from so you can fairly
clearly see that
if you draw some kind of shape that
the message passing starts at kind of
the
most symbolic parts of the
digits and here they have some chimeric
digits or
something they call it like this and
just
pay attention to where the messages
start and you can
clearly see that this sort of local
determination of what a digit is will
spread out over time to the other cells
and i thought there was this last thing
ah this thing yes so
here not only do they visualize the cell
state so the color of the cell
and that's the thing on the left is
always the first
10 entries in this hidden state but on
the right they also
visualize the other hidden entries and
so
each entry is represented by a two color
thing where
blue is very low number red is a very
high number
and here you can see what these latent
states
pass around and also you can fairly
clearly see
that they do pass around these kind of
typical sub shapes of the
digit so in the case of a zero that's
going to be a bend in the case of a four
that's going to be these ends and
corners of the numbers
and you can see that over time as
these messages pass also the
cell states on the left the visible
states
the class labels change over time this
lends a lot of credence so especially
the six i like
if you or if the two you can see in the
different if you kind of look at the
different
latent states that the kind of typical
the bends the corners
every latent state is sort of assigned
to one of them
and then they pass this information
around in order to reach an agreement
so i like this research pretty cool
research it
don't want to say it's very useful but
certainly it's very interesting
and i also like the format in this
distill format
i think that's sort of the future of
research rather than eight page pdfs you
can look at it it's interactive you can
have a little demo in it
you can write for as long as you want
and
um yeah it's just over overall better
this is still going
it doesn't know what it is so lastly you
can
as i said you can clearly see that look
if i do this it's a zero but if i do
this
then this stem part will immediately go
for a six because that's indicative of a
six but then it will disagree
with the with the zero part of the digit
in fact i seem to be unable to write a
six is that an american six
maybe uh yeah so with that
i'll leave this here i think this is
again very interesting this kind of
biological models
and certainly if you're looking for an
exciting research directions
this might be it and you do not need a
lot of resources to do this this is very
parameter
efficient as we saw in the last paper
and
certainly kind of a niche right now so
that was it for me i hope you enjoyed
this if you liked it share it out
and bye bye see you next time